a judge has thrown Kerry Lake's lawsuit
over the Arizona gubernatorial election
into the trash where it belongs this is
great news and it is the right thing
judge tosses Carrie Lakes election
Challenge and Arizona governor's race
this happened on Christmas Eve a perfect
day to usher in putting this in the
trash a judge on Saturday dismissed
Kerry Lake's election challenge remember
what happened in Arizona very
complicated okay pay really close
attention to what happened in Arizona
more people voted for Katie Hobbs
so she gets to be the governor
that's what happened in Arizona okay
the judge dismissed it
saying Lake failed to prove her case
Maricopa County Judge Peter Thompson who
oversaw the two-day trial ruled that
Lake's legal team never offered a clear
and convincing evidence showing the
election was rigged against her of
course she didn't there is no such
evidence
because it wasn't rigged
Lake can appeal the case before Katie
Hobbs is sworn in on January 2nd because
of the timetable the case may move
swiftly to the Arizona Supreme Court
Thompson noted real problems did affect
the election but election workers tried
their best and performed their role with
Integrity not perfectly as no system on
Earth is perfect but more than
sufficient to comply with the law and
conduct a valid election
okay here is her statement after
predicting endless victories she issued
this statement by the way if you're
watching
she stands like Trump now she's doing
that thing where she hinges forward at
the waist and it looks like it kind of
defies gravity
she's even standing like Trump it's
bizarre here she's calling this a win I
guess I'm just going to make a quick
statement I am so incredibly proud of
our amazing attorneys I genuinely don't
know how people stand like that not that
put this amazing case together historic
case we proved without a shadow of a
doubt that there was malicious intent
that caused disruption so great it
changed the results of the election they
did not prove that they absolutely did
not prove that incredibly proud of a
bulk Bryan by the way had she proven
that the judge would have made a
different decision Olson who let up this
legal team we provided expert testimony
we provided experts the other side
brought in activists to try to save face
they admitted that they've known about
these ballot problems they're ballot
problems now they're trying to say that
it's been going on for three elections
our elections are a mess in this country
all right so anyway I guess she's saying
it's a moral victory of some kind I
don't really know she also tweeted about
this quote my election case provided the
world with evidence
there was no evidence presented that
proves there was no proof our elections
are run outside of the law
that is not true
this judge did not rule in our favor
that's accurate okay however for the
sake of restoring faith and honesty in
our elections I will appeal this ruling
now I just want to remind you the level
of confusion around this entire thing
Carrie Lake said part of her evidence
was that people weren't allowed to vote
because they arrived after the polls
closed understand part of her evidence
is the polls are closed people show up
they're told we're closed that's
evidence it was rigged listen to this
this is truly amazing we have serious
problems with the way our elections are
run let me just read from some
affidavits of people who were taking
part in election day voting which was
now even remember affidavits are not
evidence they can be introduced as
evidence and evaluated like testimony
but doesn't even matter the massive
number of Republicans and independents
who showed up this man says at seven
o'clock
a marshall announced that voting time
was over to the line outside of the
building with over a hundred voters
still standing in line okay now those
voters in line do get to vote but listen
carefully to what she says four or five
voters arrived immediately thereafter
and were very upset one voter came to
the side door to speak to a supervisor
so understand
four to five voters arrived after the
polls closed what happens when the polls
close is they say okay you sir or ma'am
are the last person in line you get to
vote
now no one else gets to get in line
every election is run this way and part
of her evidence is an affidavit that
four or five people showed up after the
poll closure announcement was made and
were upset they weren't allowed to vote
the polls were closed these are the
rules in every state so the correct
decision by the judge she's not going to
be the governor the person who got more
votes is going to get to be the governor
we'll have all of these clips on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show
did you know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water sometimes I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the new year staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman the link is down below